people go oh you're hard done mine up we
didn't win enough games right
fact that's your job as a manager win
enough games the eight games that
romanian were arguably the best run of
games on paper so that was the only way
i couldn't get i was like well that's
the best run and you're taking this out
two days before the best run well if
you've got a lap dance you'd have to
spin again so you're fine to get the
number of so when you do the laptop
genius
to be associated with that group and to
get promoted was just off the scale
bournemouth is there anything there um
[Music]
what's happening everyone and welcome to
sport bible stories today alongside
steve oda madman we are on our debut
episode how you feeling steve
mate don't call me steve
um
feeling great man yeah this is
what an opportunity we've got here to
speak to some
legends icons and you're not you're not
you're not joking i mean today for the
debut it is the one the only it is
premier league icon sean dyson
so much better about myself with that
welcome
honestly big this is
this is like speaking purely for myself
here this is
big for me like to be to meet you like
this and to have the honor of working
with you i genuinely believe you are a
premier league icon so to see you here
today is huge and thank you so much for
coming on this debut episode no problem
you did describe it as we're working
together we're not no
you're just gonna ask me some questions
i can click that bit now you see that's
for the show so that's that's in the bag
now
yeah with colleagues
sean dyche and i are colleagues we are
working together yeah we're going of
course so before we carry on we've got
some quickfire some quick fire questions
for you if you're happy to uh absolutely
to go for it steve i do want to get us
underway
yeah um first question
what's your name
sean mark deutsch see i didn't know that
that is a bit of information we didn't
know where are you from
catrin born in kettering occupation
was
professional football manager recently
until cruelly sacked
obviously i agree with that by the way
we'll get into that but there's a bit of
fun in that book
um what club did you support growing up
seven years kid so i spotted liverpool
my local club catrin so i'll catch her
in town my dad used to go down and watch
them uh they were pretty big concerning
the non-league saying that but yeah
liverpool from a distance and your
favorite footballer when growing up
gotta be king kenny met him and the most
bizarre circumstances because obviously
i'm a man he treats you like you're a
man in football and you're just in my
brain i'm just going for your kin kenny
and he's just chatting to me all right
you know going all right burnley and i'm
still going you're you're king kenny let
me head you know and i just want to go
you'll be you're king k and is this
later right now are you actually no i'm
not the same mate i gotta be honest i'm
me but that's king kenny is this when
you were different sean dutch
top manager yeah yeah i just i was at a
game actually um i think weirdly i think
i was in the championship and he was at
a preston game
i can't remember why he was there i was
there and he just walked down and tapped
my shoulder and said all right sean that
was the first time and then when i went
to anfield i met him a bit you know
properly sort of thing
um and it's just that weird thing you
know they they say don't meet your
heroes trust me king khan is a proper
legend so did you have that moment when
you met him was it was
a star no did you have a photo no
because you've been in football when
when you when you're 16 and you go in as
an apprentice in my day i went to
northern forest and there's some big
players and they were like top five you
know league well then division one club
before the prem winning cups and that so
you've got some big figures there then
you know i mean dez walker stuart pierce
nigel cluff you know amongst many others
that's just three off the back
and it sort of takes it away you realize
that they're people they
they're people are sports people so it
kind of takes that away but but deep
down because your kid memory it's like
in kenneth you know you know he's seven
and you've got his shirt on and you
think it's king kenny yeah that's the
thing
the hero that you have when you're youth
it's very difficult for that to not
remain your hero like for example for me
dennis wise will always be a kid like if
i if i were to ever meet dennis wise i
would be 12 again everyone would feel i
mean i have but i did i didn't maintain
my composure you know what i didn't get
the photo i didn't do anything garage i
was such i was proper into garage music
so i just thought you meant
i've been very fortunate i've got many
contacts now in music and i love meeting
them guys you know can you sing or play
can i can you check with a quick start i
know we're on quick fire but it's a good
story
so the other night i was at leeds
festival um melvin benosia and a
brilliant unbelievably unassuming classy
fella has looked after me interjected a
an email about five years ago
i just cold called it said could you
sort me out with some tickets my kids
and all that because i get acting granny
out of at these festivals so i said you
know just a little vip have a drink with
my kids and i
been amazingly generous ever since
anyway so i'm at leeds festival the
night get uh wingside on the stage for
the arctic monkeys so i'm walking back
off around the back of the stage
and i see alex i literally go
alex great gig i was on my own i said
great gig my kids are in the thinking of
my daughter alyssia and i said great gig
so he did that weird thing he sort of
checked he shook me and checked and then
you know walked off about 10 years you
know the thing when he went
i could see in his face
yeah like type thing so anyway a day
later a fellow called johnny owens um
who did this yeah i believe in miracles
now about forest i mean he's become a
good friend of mine
he sends a message so he knows that he's
on the first um arty monkey's album
called something mcclure i can't think i
don't know chris mcclure yeah he goes
with the [ __ ] on the on the picture yeah
that's on the first uh arc among his
album yeah he was sitting with alex
after the gig sends this text away she
goes by the way tell your mate shawn
alex said this and he goes i was walking
down off the stage and this guy was out
and he said i gotta be honest i thought
is he part of the team he looked a bit
like maybe like part of our group or not
not the singing group you know the the
people who look after him yeah security
stage managers yeah
security or whatever and then realize
that short nights and you said what a
way to finish a festival when you met by
sean knight amazing i was buzzing i was
like yeah also higher praise
tony's genius isn't it they're amazing
but first time i've seen them as well
that's why i specifically went really
yeah when i went on the saturday and saw
dave and people like look really good
new to me my daughter's into that so
they're good really good aj tracy if you
like good
um yeah and
corkin city i really likes i saw them
and then arty monkeys were excellent
without that just a weird moment so
that's amazing there's some doors open
for you and these weird moments come out
because because he is
he's a hero as well well back to the
point was that what you were saying so
i'd be more that i'd sort apart from
king kenny of course that'd be more to
me meeting them people and sometimes i
get a drink with them and have a beer
and chat about their lives
and do you feel like um because you
think i i don't know if you find this
when you speak to other people say in
entertainment or in a professional space
it's all the same all the lines yeah i
really like elite anything so i've i've
seen music loads of elite events which
i've been invited to not always into
what they are but into what you're
saying into the background of it the the
management the
alignment of the teams and all stuff
like that and it does cross over many
many times you know even
especially in modern music now they've
got it they've got to be out there
gigging because obviously the downfall
of record sales so they've got to be out
there doing it and therefore they've got
to be on it they've got to be stripped
back but raw but they've still got a bit
of line they've still got to be really
producing the days of maybe the stories
in the 70s the band's going on steam
no no they're they're very good they're
very fear yeah they're elite they're
knocking up on point all the time so
it's changed anyway sorry i've got a
quick fight
so
leading on from that what is your
favorite thing to do outside of football
i really i do really like music i'm not
obsessed by music but i love seeing um
gigs um but but that's more of a social
thing golf i love playing golf but to
knock it because i had three two back
operations in the last four years but
i've recently started again uh i've i've
got time to leave on a minute um so yeah
i really love golf um i don't compete at
it i just like playing are you any good
do something you seem like an idol
when i when i was playing a lot before
my back
decent round about 10. okay but reason
been really bad i mean really bad so i'm
i was working progress to get back to
where i was let's say so favorite
footballer ever kenny douglas
uh no no nor for the fact that you're a
kid right ever
he could be up there with maradona you
know that was my era seeing maradona at
his prime you know what i mean so that
it's hard to see beyond you know them um
modern wise probably ronaldo just
because he went to the other clubs
messi's unbelievable but just because
messages at one club went until recently
and ronaldo went to others and did it
everywhere he goes what about managers
when you were growing up was there a
manager
well yeah again the seven is you know
bob paisley in the era of the uh boot
room manager but then sir alex really
you know i've been very fortunate to get
to know him a little bit and he's always
very generous to me and at the stadium
he invites me into his room afterwards
and all that i mean what he did with the
club and
you know what we've seen since he come
out of that club in comparison it's just
crazy unbelievable for all them years at
that club that level that pressure that
intensity them signings remolding
rethinking regenerating year on year
i've heard about those moments with
ferguson he'll he'll often invite the
opposing manager into his office for a
drink after the game is that actually
without you stopping a lot um but it's a
different thing now a lot of the foreign
managers it's not just part of their
culture it's not it's not they're not
against it some some grow into it i mean
pochettino did um arsene wenger did with
us not always but not with everyone
apparently but he did with us and
burnley maybe weren't exactly a threat
to
um
yeah so it's a dying thing that but not
because there's any offense taken it's
just because it's a cultural difference
you know do you ever see okay do you do
that yeah if they want to come in there
the doors the doors are open oh you know
pre pandemic and after pandemic but you
gotta mean the doors always open it's
some some do some don't there's uh
no no when that happens
what do you chat about it depends who's
one yeah yeah you know he's one you know
what what are you gonna someone just say
some really odd things when you're like
really you know like they've beat you
and that they're actually sort of
nailing you a little bit you know what i
mean
like and
if we played five aside or played
monopoly or saying and after defeat yeah
no most aggression some of you know
right so if you know steve bruce you're
going to have a bit of fun
brilliant brilliant fella by the way um
you're going to have a bit not fun but
sometimes serious but generally there is
it's a it's a moment when you're
fighting on the sidelines but in the
room afterwards you're cool you know and
he's a top top fella by the way tops
who's steve bruce oh brilliant fella do
you think it was harshly true because by
the end of newcastle there's no point in
worrying about harsh intrigue you're
going to get harshly treated football
don't be a manager unless you think
you're going to get asked your training
because you are going to get hungry at
some point yeah no i mean very few don't
know in terms of your proudest moment in
football is there one
sort of standout moment for you that you
put above everything else well it's got
to be the the well as a regards
management there's got to be there's got
to be the the first promotion of burnley
because it was
you know no one thought it could happen
and it just grew as the season went on
um a bit i suppose a bit although we did
it automatically a bit kind of like the
sheffield united story a bit kind of
like the forest story but it was a few
years ago and we just
got that momentum going players playing
at the top of what they were doing and
and to to to be associated with that
group and to get promoted was just off
the scale life changer for everyone have
you got someone
in football that's like you you
obviously you say ferguson's become
you've been talking to him over the
years is there someone that you consider
your most influential person in football
yeah probably someone you wouldn't know
much about um and unfortunately he's
very very ill at the moment so you know
i hope he hope he finds his way but um
john duncan who's at chesterfield with
us oh yes yeah very um probably
influenced me i didn't know then because
you're a bit younger i was probably
around 24 25 26 around that i can't
remember exactly before i moved to
bristol city had a couple of seasons
with him he stood by me from a contract
point of view which was the first person
who had i felt um made sure i was looked
after the best possible from a small
club like chesterfield
i delivered back for him and we got on
great and his assistant who sadly passed
away kevin randlew like i say we we grew
a relationship still speak to him now
and still use them as to bounce opinions
off of
because he'd watch all our games and
stuff and he's very honest guys he's not
going to give you some bluff he's just
going to say exactly what he's saying
but you know everything that he's saying
he's going to tell you so you need that
you know
you can't be too precious in being
management you need people to give you
an outside view just just literally as
they see it not that kind of
you know they did well here and they did
well there you ain't got time for that
you need it you need it just bang there
you go that's what i think
but then it depends on the type of
person you're giving the information to
can they go away not take things to
heart
like well you're learning it over the
years i mean it's it's it's very you
know as a player you i think now more
than ever you know with the um the
growth and the power of social media
it's probably more of a precious thing
that we're looking for good news but as
a manager you can't you're gonna get bad
news it's not i'm not being negative you
just are i'll give you a quick example
when we got prior that first season i
was saying about amazing situation
amazing season out of nowhere got
promoted
to the premier league we were at the
player of the year dude and fan come to
me and said um sean it's been amazing
this season but i've got to ask you why
don't you leave anyone up at corners and
you know when you just think
yeah please everyone
you know i mean you're just never going
to do it so therefore you just have to
accept and that's when you're winning
all the time so when you're not winning
trust me you're going to get some heat
was there ever a standout piece of
advice that you've sort of took to heart
and have lived by since
um well
i know about standard advice but a
brilliant bit of management we made the
fa cup semi-final for people who
wouldn't know but chesterfield that was
a massive thing against middlesbrough
and um i remember in the dressing room
yeah again these are things at the time
they're just funny moments but when you
look back genius management and i
remember he got everyone in and and this
is john duncan he gets everyone in and
he says hey hey and he's deadly serious
i can't do all of his action but he's
got a quirky accent and he says
he lads he says look at you you look
like you're all [ __ ] yourself
someone's sitting there we're all going
on anyway i hope you're [ __ ] hard
cause i [ __ ] know yeah
and it just took the fire out you know
everyone just relaxed and he said hey
let's take it on you know and it was a
moment of genius because everyone's dead
no you know chesterfield in the fa cup
semi-final it's enormous royal trafford
i can't tell you you know people who
can't see they've been sawing tickets so
we're known to do all that we're doing
everything i was captaining i was
running the players pool sorting tickets
out you get to i mean like
yeah almost thinking oh we've got the
game now what game yeah and he just
defused it all with a just a very simple
moment a bit of humor and i remember
thinking genius i think that is genius
have you taken that on like would that
have stayed in a way in a way i mean
look times have changed you know there
was a lot it was a different era then
you know players now you've got almost
give them everything if you go don't
give them everything it's like well you
didn't tell me this and you didn't tell
me that you didn't tell me that so the
trust and the belief in
letting you
show what you can do and believe in what
you can do and deliver what you can do
now you've almost got to give players
everything it's like you know sport
would call it a no excuse mentality the
thing is with that
and i was talking recently about this
you have to be really careful because
you want to give a no no excuse mentally
in a novice excuse environment even
better
but guess what then it becomes a crutch
to lean on because then it's like well
you didn't tell him this and you didn't
tell me you didn't tell me that he could
kick it with his left foot his right
foot he's and his arm and his leg and
every part of his body you know and i'm
going yeah i shouldn't have to you know
you're a professional footballer yeah
yeah yeah so that's changed and and
that's where the delicate line now of
modern management is giving definitely
an environment for this no excuse
situation but making it clear to the
players right we've given you that now
it's for your responsibility to take
that on and deliver it and i think
that's a fine line now and it's really
it's a really difficult line at times
yeah our final quick fire question is
that i've been the slowest quick fighter
sorry no
i think it's like we're learning on the
job here remember this is our debut as
well for a very loose term yeah does um
is there one thing that you couldn't
live without if you've got one treasured
possession is there something that
stands out that's like any you know if
you if you've had kids your kids i mean
that's you know that's just one of them
things it's like an unbinding
uh combination of feelings that you
can't well i can't you can't put into
words they're just there and you just
you just know that they are and you need
them there when you can see them i need
to know they're well and they're safe
that's pretty more like it other than
that not really
i like material things but i'm not into
it you know what i mean i got a nice car
but i'm not into it it doesn't define me
you know somebody will actually change
they get a car
it's a car it's still just a car so i'm
not really into that side of things i've
got some amazing nice things but you get
what i mean i'm not really the car park
of a like of a premier league football
team is insane isn't it like when you
see the car sort of like i mean i think
they go through different generations
players you know it depends on your age
group
your players you know because some go
through that stage and then they realize
it it's just a car and then they go back
to just drive you know i don't know if
you remember there was a famous period i
know they were sponsored by them but i
think this is right i think the manu
players were driving in an audi's or
something
yeah so they all had fleets of cars but
they used to drive in and out of their
houses because it was almost like the
menu thing you know we just we just
crack on
you know that's not so easy now because
you've got you've got also remember that
as much as i like a pretty tight
environment they're still human beings
yeah you know if you put 50 grand in my
pocket when i was 19 as if i wouldn't
have a car a proper car course you would
yeah so you've got to just be realistic
and go well you know just go young it
doesn't make them all
you know
an egg because they drive a big fancy
car yeah some equally don't believe in
it they just can yeah so they drive a
big car but they don't actually believe
in it they're still working they're
still playing they're still it's just
that fine line i mean we're only using a
car as an example you can imagine all
the other trinkets that come along that
fine line of
do they believe the car makes them
better or different
sometimes you gotta educate that go whoa
whoa it's just a car yeah
i think more nowadays with influencers
social media
you can get proper call you could get
caught
back in the day but now i just feel like
with the the it's the first the finances
that come with being a footballer young
now yeah like obviously when you when
you were playing you earn
and you built your way up and then
hopefully at some point in your career
no you're right i mean that is is the
the conundrum of modern football life as
in financially because
players are getting rewarded without
doing anything yeah but that's just the
nature of it because they're
they're buying the potential to do
something so do you feel like i don't
know if we're even here yet but i'm
gonna go with it but the likes of these
young players like this i don't want to
name names to be honest i don't like
that they're names
i'm not talking about for instance okay
i'll name one recent um ross barkley
like
how good was he now there's two ways i
look at this i do remember him getting
through some serious injuries and
whatnot so i know he does have strong
mentality right but then
do you get too much too soon yeah josh
josh mchetran at chelsea definitely got
too much for this because brother as
well yeah man like it's too much too
soon because some couldn't go on with
like um odigo
he went to real madrid 16
kept sticking at it and now he's like 22
23 um
and he's going to have a long career
about something he's going to really his
character i'm not i'm not saying
anything about names but it's just
different characters respond to
different things that come their way do
you see that you just have a natural
instinct to
want to win all the time
you know what you know what is a is a
food for thought thing
you know some footballers are just good
at it yeah yeah man but people think
they should love every minute of it
they've actually grown up going i don't
actually love everything i'm just really
good at it do you know my eyes
i remember reading an interview from him
and it completely blew my mind
he didn't like football yeah he just
happened to excel at it he happened to
have the the natural innate ability yeah
i've never necessarily come across where
you don't like it but there's a
difference between being obsessed loving
it and everything that fans think and
some just happened to be really good at
it and they got to an age like oh
yeah i'm so good at this why wouldn't i
carry on yeah but doesn't mean it
dominates their lives the modern
football is very rare they are football
dominant yeah there's so much going on
in their lives you know what i mean you
partied with burnley in april mm-hmm
have you been following the football
you're watching it are you obsessed or
whatever you're doing well distantly but
not it's time for me to have a break i
didn't need the break just to be clear i
didn't come out needing a break you know
someone said i was tired and i wasn't um
i was more than happy to crack on but
just to clear that up by the way in case
you can ask like but i'll clear it up
now don't forget that people go oh you
had done mine up we didn't win enough
games right
fact that's your job as a manager win
enough games so i would never hide
behind that there's other reasons i'm
not going to get millions of different
reasons about whys and wherefores but
the facts are the facts we had a team
that could have won more games and we
didn't win enough games i think you're
being strong
as well
because you haven't lost it
you don't know me if that was my mates
they'd go yeah that's what i think i get
it
i understand i think i think that you're
obviously you are onto something you
didn't win enough games i think that's
honest and and applicable to the
situation i also think
there's lost enough you haven't lost
enough games you weren't down no no the
argument would be and and i said this on
part in was that the eight games that
were remaining were arguably the best
run of games on paper because the
premier league's very difficult by the
way but on paper the best runner games
of the season yeah so that was the only
but i couldn't get i was like well
that's the best run and you're taking us
out two days before the best run yeah so
that bit i couldn't get that
but
they're under pressure to make decisions
the owners not an easy decision if you
look at it the other way big decision
big brave decision for someone who'd
been there as long as i had yeah what
about the blanket that you had created
in the sense of seven years was it seven
seven seasons keeping bernie in the
premier league yeah uh no six six up but
we had seven out of eight
lady gags we went up down yes
yes yes um right surely
yeah but like i say with it with all
that being considered you've still got
one enough games and we hadn't and i
felt the team although weren't a
brilliant team
but we had enough in our locker to have
won more games than we did and not be in
the situation we did it it's still going
to be tight i mean i told the new owners
when they first come in i said the next
company is going to be really tight
because we've got to regenerate the
squad because there hadn't been the
investment put in three years ago
because they were trying to sell the
club therefore they kept the money in
the club blah blah blah
so we were always going to be playing
catcher but
facts are facts we still had the players
capable of winning more games than we
did i feel there was a period where
people would look at burnley be like
burnley
tough ground to go to all of that and
they worked hard then there was a change
where it's laying on at no point last
year when you managed to did i say they
go down even when even when the windless
streak was going on at no point and i
was always saying they'll be up dutch
that's what i was always saying even
what up until the point i i i wouldn't
i'm not it's like i believed he would
have
but
you never know do you feel there was a
change though when people were saying
like right burnley they're actually a
good team that like they're a good team
like we have to and then did the players
you know do you know what that comes
with and it comes from managers as well
um and possibly certain media streams so
you know you get in there and it's
exciting and it's new right so you're
burning everyone goes well they've done
amazing let's see what happens so you
get that for a couple of scenes you
stand oh wow it's all amazing then you
go through the say you're at year three
and then it's like oh they're just doing
this that on the other then you go
through oh my goodness they do this and
they're hard and that
and then you go and then people go fair
platinum you know they're in the premier
league again so you almost it's like the
you know the the sort of
the reverse bell curve you know you
start high and people sort of do you
down a bit do you down a bit and then
they have to no choice and the managers
are almost like
you're here
do you feel they took the foot off the
gas the players or the yeah
we had some brilliant pros who were
amazing and they'd achieved massive for
themselves for the team for me for the
club massively so i'm never going to
question all what about what's next are
you looking forward to getting back into
management yeah i'm not i'm not uh i'm
not pushing or anything you know i keep
i get linked but let's face it i'm out
there i've just come out of a job
relatively successful in the sense of
years of service to a club and keeping
them up so i'm probably going to be
linked not with all jobs but i'm
probably going to be linked so that's
just par for the course i was in the
black cab this morning
excuse me in the paper there's a mention
a gentle homage to you regarding the
bournemouth job
yeah but like i say you're going to get
linked with i was linked when i was in a
job mm-hmm
you know when you're out of a job if you
think about it you've got in theory no
compensation sales picture you've got no
compensation you've got a good record
you know what you're doing yeah handsome
debonair
what's not to like yeah no you know what
i mean there's
you're going to be linked because when
you're in a job don't forget no joking
apart but the business side of it does
kick in clubs are looking and they might
be going oh you know and then they look
at your contract compensation
sometimes they aggro to get through that
and the other club sometimes just go
right there it is but others you know
it's a negotiation it all gets a bit
weird and a bit odd as we've seen many
times through football whereas when
you're not
um would it prevail bournemouth is there
anything there there's nothing that i
wouldn't look at because i think i've
been around my career was through every
division played in every i didn't plan
the premier league but loads of cup
games against premier league clubs i
played in all the other divisions i
managed in the championship the premier
league as well
i'd never disrespect any club i mean to
give you a view of that when i come out
what for those people like
crawley find me straight away because um
steve cobble was involved yeah phoned me
straight away and i said look steve i
just want to afford myself a window yeah
but i was respectful of that drinks cool
had a really good chat with him spoke
through it all you know what i mean i've
been around the game a long way since i
was 16 so
i found that you know be careful if
you're going to start i mean i'll give
you a quick one i see these young
managers they're on tv or whatever and
they go yeah i'm looking for the right
project and the right people who's not
yeah
get a job first yeah not easy to get a
job yeah what about would you ever
consider doing something like that like
i love the idea yeah i mean it's popular
about that sort of stuff there's loads
of myths you know what i mean i didn't
like
foreign players why wouldn't you they're
just players you want players who are
good and make you better yeah we just
didn't have the resources at burnley or
the mindset from the old board more so
from the new board to do that
just as an example same with uh going
abroad why wouldn't you you do you got
your family reasons the point is if you
take away your life and just went would
you manage abroad oh yeah why wouldn't
you why why would you not be open-minded
to that it's just football right it's
football
in the office any conversations ever
it's been conversations in the past but
you know more sounding out you've got to
remember in the industry that it is um
you might have an agent but that doesn't
stop other agents phoning your
messaging yeah i've got some funny ones
for you so recently i keep getting
whatsapps from uh european agents who
are saying that would you be interested
in this plan i have to put you down as
i'm not in a job anymore
because they because they just
probably on the mailing list well we've
got it trolling so they'll just throw it
out there and hope to get a bite you
know what i mean they'll just they'll
just trawl and hope that somewhere
another might be you get another job or
they don't even know hearted well they
know exactly you know what you might
speak to another manager though and say
you know what i don't know i'm not
really one world figure but you'd like
to think if you're an agent you know
that i wasn't working here probably
currently yeah surely you know when
you're not working so when you when that
conversation happens like this is an
insight you know i kind of dedicated my
life to football as much as i've i talk
about it every day i
play it as often as possible and yeah i
know nothing about the game but from
your point of view you know when i read
the club and the manager have parted
ways yeah
what what does that mean like how does
it like do you go in is there a sit-down
meeting it depends it depends on the
legalities so sometimes the terminology
will be decided on the legalities of
contracts right you know my mom was
pretty simple affair allen pace decent
fella by the way
just came in one morning said could i
meet you know by the way you can smell
you know yeah yeah i've been in the game
all my life you know what i don't know
how do you know what's the little odd
odd meeting time yeah yeah like
somebody at eight o'clock in the morning
so uh game of golf the day before
equally odd yeah so uh you know like you
know these are these are just the little
signs you know what i mean um
feeling around your group around the
training ground because you know often
these rumors and murmurings start
um so yeah but a simple affair sat down
taught me through it i got my opinion
very very quickly nothing said no
problem just look after the people that
you want to remove you'll have no
problem for me all right and what about
the opposite of that then you know when
you're
perhaps they call it being tapped up is
that how it works you know if you how
does that no no
sometimes it's just straightforward as
well they've gone to the club they've
they've asked permission they know your
contract they the club know the contract
and all that sort of stuff
you're making dry snitch on himself
saying he's been tapped up in that no no
no no no
yeah you'll ask me a question i'll give
you an answer and if i don't give you
the answer i won't answer it
simple
i do find that fascinating because in my
head it's like really glamorous like are
you not being wooed at the ivy are you
not being sort of taken for a second i
certainly haven't been i mean maybe that
goes on
certainly not me maybe they didn't think
i was that kind of guy but deep down i
am a bit of a foodie so you've got
another exclusive there we go
yeah
we're talking about like
managers when they say oh
i want to go into a good project and
they know what they want from a club
they're going to go to but what's deal
breakers like what makes you like club
not going to that um
well when you're in the game a long time
like i've been you you can keep your
finger on
what's going on behind the scenes at
clubs so you sometimes hear about
ownerships about um you know situations
with clashes of achieve execs director
football or whatever it may be so you
might be going oh i'm not sure about
that
whilst being open-minded enough to go
well could i manage that because you
know you're a manager don't forget the
idea is you you you're in the light yeah
exactly that's the point if you look at
it logically you're there
to align that situation yeah so
therefore if that's your job and that's
what you're tasked with and that's what
you've got to do i mean my belief in
management to give you a feel of it and
i've always made this clear to the
owners of burning well watford burnley
and the new owners at burnley
just tell me what i've got to manage
what's hard for a manager is when you
get told you've got to manage this
and then a month later this comes along
you know what in a minute yeah so now
the gold coast gold posts keep changing
and different figures keep doing you're
going right okay so where was the
structure we all agreed on
usually the best scenario in my
experience is
tell me what you want me to manage
and i'll manage it to the best of my
politics
money's a big one sorry money's a big
one so just tell me that we haven't got
any money and i manage the best i can
with no money or time we have got some
money the greyness is really hard for
managers and do you generally get that
transparency or do you find that it's
off i did it burnley with i did it
burnley with the structure and the
belief and i did it i did it actually at
watford with graham gran taylor rest his
soul bro brilliant fella um his
alignment you know he's very because
he'd been legend you know manager and he
understood it so it's quite clear um but
the old board at burnley was was very
clear because i worked with them for
time and obviously over time you build a
more clarity they were never clear with
money though they always had none even
though we had bundles always no man you
weren't from zero and maybe get a bit so
that was always that was a challenge um
uh yeah so so in my experience of that
new ownership changed that feeling a
little bit you know
and i don't there is the exact perfect
model other than
in my opinion just just be honest tell
me what i've got to manage yeah and then
what about taking your own team like is
is ian won a prerequisite you know in
those conversations do you say my own
team no i mean well another another kind
of i don't want to say a myth but i'll
give you an idea of it so when i first
went into watford as manager you go for
people like won't in and people think
you're bringing in your mate now here's
my mate but he's a completely different
character to me massively different
characters so my idea was to build a
team around me that were different
because if you're not got difference you
don't get the right
feedback he needs someone who's going to
look at things differently someone's
different character someone's going to
feel it differently so i had him tony
lockland tony locklear's very
organized writes down sessions keeps a
map of everything that he does so that
was his skill set to keep us you know i
could say it's time tony you want to
freshen up we could do that and it did
pull out a file with eight years ago a
training session on a tuesday our you
know morning from eight years ago and go
right uh gaff we did this blah blah and
you go brilliant
won't it was different to that i'm
obviously different to that more
straight up you know full-on black and
white thinking
quite i think i'm good at structure and
strategy and all that sort of stuff
steve stone came in working with the 20s
then stepped up different again
different kind of character vibrant
geordi you know a bit full-on bit
abandoned with a last bit of full-on
sort of feeling
all these characters make a team
so now that's your question it would
there be a new team possibly but would
would i at least have a chance with that
team of people yeah because i know how
they work they know i work they know the
expectation of what you want yeah so
you're already off and running whereas
when you work with new people which
sometimes happen has to happen you know
you get a new team around you you've got
to work each other out at least i know
them guys how does it work on the
training ground would you be on the
training ground or would you leave that
to a different
i was always out there but in the early
days you'd i was hands-on a lot because
i wanted to lay down this is my
expectation of everything we do
and then over time you your staff get
more and more involved you learn to
delegate better and you trust delegate
better and then you can let things go a
bit further you know and you'll let the
coaches take training you'd always
oversee it some days i'd summarize it
and sometimes i wouldn't some days i'd
just be on the peripheral some days i'd
be heavily involved i mean some of it
comes from a feel you know you look at
the group and you learn how to monitor
the group you get to a point with you
know we're all humans we all interact
within five seconds you say good morning
someone you know what mood they're in
you know what state they're in you know
what i mean just by their their quick
body language their quick
answer back
if you found that some fun players if
you found that someone was in they've
come in they might have had an argument
with their misses or whatever it may be
and they've come in in a bit of a
a weird mood and it might affect their
training will you give them a bit of
leeway thinking okay like sometimes it's
your staff's job to pick up on that and
it depends your staff sometimes feed it
back to you go look i've heard that so
inside a few problems there you know so
i'd pull them is everything right do you
need anything you know try and be
supportive been through some amazingly
challenging things off the pitch and
that that is a thing that maybe
sometimes things like give you a chance
to explain you know
footballers of course they're seen as a
product and and you know that's it but
they have lives they have lives and
people go oh yeah but they've got money
money isn't solved money can bring
trouble it doesn't solve everything you
know what i mean so they forget that
sometimes you've seen these players
running around on a football pitch you
don't know what's happened the night
before the day before i do and sometimes
you've got to put them out there knowing
they're carrying a lot off the pitch but
of course then your professional side
kicks in and that's what people forget i
say this to young when i was dealing
with young players apprentices at
watford i said always remember this on
your passport it doesn't say football it
says professional footballer
that's what you're gonna learn to be the
professional because everyone wants to
be a footballer everyone wants to go and
run around and play and have fun and
earn loads of money everyone wants to do
that be successful etc what about the
professional bit what about doing all
that it takes including when the
hardships are hitting you in your
private life can you still go worse yeah
that's that's your job you know what
biggie said don't you
when it comes to money
more money more problems
just checking in
he was checking let's check i
well i think i know that when it comes
to the mind you're very
big on that i think right um do you
enjoy getting a player and working
you can get a player and you can work on
his technical side of things right you
can get his touch better you can get his
movement and or you can build him as a
human i've always thought
if you affect the uh person you'll
affect their performance
so i always try and build
an alignment of rapport of trust
belief in each other two way not just me
dominating them go look this is what i
think it'll be good for you good for the
team what are your thoughts and then we
find the negotiables and the
non-negotiables so
there's a fine line between them but
it's important i wasn't against being
involved with the group i'd be around
the group i was quite happy with that a
bit of fun they knew i was the manager
they knew where the line was and if that
got crossed then
i'd make sure they didn't get crossed
and i was quite open with that sort of
that feeling if you like amongst the
group but i i wanted them to know that
i'm with you and i'll protect you and
i'll help you and all you have to do is
make me 50 50. if you make me halfway
i'll give you my all if you don't then
we're gonna have to have a word it's
tough to get that balance man i i ended
up getting a restaurant right and being
the owner
but i don't consider myself as a
boss i don't like it i really hate it
and i'm in with the the workers and i'm
getting the tequila out and i'm giving
shots out and all of this and then when
it comes to putting your foot down how
do you put your foot down when yesterday
you're doing tequila shots with them and
all of that you know i mean so i just
the balance for me i couldn't do it in
the end i've got rid of the restaurant i
can't i'm not i'm not boss-like i just
don't have it in me i'll be honest with
you i don't know how it did but if
you're shooting tequila's with a staff
before you even put the food out
yeah
i don't imagine that's like the kids i
was awful
you know you're right i mean i don't go
that far um if we did take the lads out
i'd have a drink with them pop in see
him from an hour and then again out of
the way you know you just do a bit of
respect you know there's that fine line
between leaving them you know what i
mean but you learn that as you go you
know i played i played all my life i've
been in football in my life you get a
feeling for your group and you know the
trust as well the trust lines going you
can trust them when you can't the
different characters you learn all that
about people yeah you know when you're
you've got a massive match on you're
playing away at the emirates on sunday
how does that week shape up for you will
you go and watch it say arsenal got a
game midweek will you go and watch that
game
sometimes depends on their well from
burnley obviously you're traveling all
the time you know so it's difficult you
know to get to where you need to go to
but if they're in the location or
somewhere get where you can get to
don't forget you have uh away analytics
now you know and i mean let's give you
another myth you know it always makes us
laugh in football not just me loads of
people in football
so you know this new manager goes into
whatever club and it's like oh yeah
they're really analytical they've got
this they've got that they've got this
and they've got that everyone's doing
that right we'll just laugh yeah yeah
that's amazing that breakthrough because
we're getting that in a breakthrough
we've all been doing that for 10 years
everyone's doing all that stuff so
you know answer your questions sometimes
we'll say we have an away scout we
usually did three reports on the
opposition um
home underway so you're getting a mixed
view of how they operate home and away
um sometimes more reports you build a
backlog of reports of course they change
your styles change your manager so
you've got that to reflect upon
you can get eyes on them if you can or
your assistant or your coach gets eyes
on them as well um but that's not just
big games you know you gotta remember
when you're burning in the premier
league every game is a big game yeah
every game's a massive game yeah you
know and
you don't you don't treat any
like we never did a throwaway like we
got we got mashed by man city year after
year but we didn't throw it away we
weren't like going um oh well
we're doing that we're still providing
the players with look we know it's
difficult but there's the truth of it
this is what they do this is what we
feel we might be able to do
to affect it etc etc we didn't go in
going on well what about prioritizing
fixtures would you ever do that yeah
there was a lot of talk about that i
mean winning the winnables and stuff
like that which which does have some
merit but but i always think you gotta
be careful because then you might you
might take away the fact that well what
what about when you do beat liverpool
away yeah and they haven't lost in 68
games like we did yeah so you might take
that away because it's like oh well this
one doesn't count yeah man cities we
beat them we drew them why not
manu chelsea yeah so i always thought
you got to be a little bit careful with
that i do understand it and i understand
the pro and and statistically by the way
it does it does work you know we
statistically would be in teams in the
bottom half of the table more than we
would be in the top half so there is a
stat that backs it i just think it's a
mindset thing i always think well you
know in my opinion why did you sort of
almost
not promote but almost offer the opinion
that oh well it sort of doesn't matter
because these matter yeah so i was
always like every game matters you know
and that's the mindset i wanted every
game you could win find a way that was
always my mindset how big is mindset
obviously i know it's big but how big is
it
like in this modern
game where i just feel
and i'm i'm old i feel like i'm old in
this in in my industry with the
influence of life they're all really
really young and when i talk i sound old
and i say back in the day they cared
more
and i feel like
that's all that's lacking from this
beautiful game that we've got now where
it's technically amazing i just think
we're missing a bit of the
the care but society has changed it's
not about you you can't rewind life you
know like society is changing you know
care and attention detail respect
respect is changing yeah you know so you
okay you're not going to rewind all you
just try and offer the well i only
offered the reasons for i said to
players these are the reasons i'll tell
you what we should be doing
but you you have to take ownership of it
you have to take ownership of how much
you care do you care one percent you
care 99 you know what that's for you to
decide so
but society is changing you you know
money managers have had to change you
know it always sort of thing that makes
me laugh he's an old school manager
trust me no it's going there is no
article managers because you can't you
can't believe it
it's impossible to be an old-school
manager you can't do it anymore yeah so
it's it's nonsense
you have to bend and flex with what's
going on or get people around you can ah
yeah yeah harry did it brilliantly at
tottenham
with uh les and tim they they sort of
went around a younger guy you know
younger they went around doing that bit
you know what i mean yeah i don't know
whether he did that particularly but
that's what it seemed to me he was
coming to age where he's probably
thought right i need some young cats
around here who are kind of just
finishing they know the script they they
can blend with the players they know
what the players need whilst he did
those players as well a lot of that team
would have looked up you know tim
sherwood obviously won the league and
les ferdinand was an illegal striker
they would have they would have been
heroes for some of those players coming
through which is helpful i don't know
where they did it for that reason yeah
but i imagine there was probably a bit
of that what i mean yeah you know when
you you touched on it there playing man
city and it wasn't always going your way
it was fairly really going your way i
was doing my best did you share him when
we got a corner did you yes
did you did you prioritize today in that
in that build-up would you worry about
your own team would you focus on your
own team or would you say right yeah
we've got to stop de bruyne we're let's
focus on deployment let's work out no
i'm always wary that you know tactically
when they got about my mark in someone
you're a man down don't forget you're
100. hopefully they are as well is that
allergic hopefully they are there you
can't read their mind
so they'll be in advance of you so you
might de bruyne he's still in advance of
your man marker yeah because he can see
it quicker than your marker can say he's
just following him so you're now a man
downs you're now 10 v 11
in theory yeah so is that not a tactic
you'd employ you don't rate that not me
personally
but with obviously you you've got to
remember that it's not often talking
about yardages so would we say if he
gets near the ball you go lock on sharp
style of course but the idea of
literally wandering around the phone is
like that
it's very i've only seen that a few
times in my life and i remember park ji
song uh following messi around for for a
game that was because he wanted his
shirt
on the back wall there is that a shirt
it's not the real one it's tiny it's
tiny hodgy in the maradona yes
it's worth a mention so we just got on
hodgy's house before we went out for a
night out now and he needs to get the
shirt out and chose it
little you know yourself for like seven
minutes it's like this big tiny little
thing really yeah do you have to just
eat it
if you've got anything in the treasure
yeah i tend to give away i'll do some
stuff for charity and stuff so i tend to
give my way and get collect stuff for
charity i've still got my fa cups final
shirt the the one i played cause you
know you get right because what i
actually played doing
and some team shows i've given stuff my
middle ones i gave to neil harris in his
testimonial and stuff like that yeah
i'm not that precious about memorabilia
to be honest i don't i don't have
anything at all
in my house at all no about my career
nothing
how comes because i always want the
family to live their lives i don't want
their lives to be about my life my
children and my missus and that's their
life they're an office in your house do
you have a do you have a sort of
managerial school but nothing in it
really no nothing in it that you'd know
about anything to do with my career gosh
with natural and that sort of philosophy
does that seep into your management
style would you say
philosophy is a word that gets banned
around it's not philosophy it's just my
part being me i just think why would i
put myself and my career on my family's
life
try and take that away and go no no you
be yourself you live your life don't be
like my lad's a footballer so
why would i want he don't want to be
seeing about me all the time he sees
enough of that particularly in the
premier league
so i never got involved with his life
and i want him to do it for him you know
what i mean i haven't been screaming
from the sidelines and all that
here's one for you wouldn't scream at
your kid when they learned how to play
the piano would you it's funny that
yeah parents screaming at kids playing
football never really got that trust me
i never did that not once did your boy
tap you up for for advice
uh yeah but only uh feedback casually
i'd i'd offer him some stuff um but not
uh not intense i certainly wouldn't be
getting his videos and breaking it all
down
unless he asked me to should say for
context sean so yours your son's
currently at northampton he is my son
he's at northampton town yeah and a half
as well yeah i mean he's just played the
other night in the cup and they got beat
six nil oh so
made sense of it didn't think he
actually did too badly as an individual
but you put it in a team that got
smashed no one cares whether you did
quite well the dad or sean the manager
yeah both bit of empathy and support
from being a dad and a bit of right okay
well he knows i'm in the game so
therefore i'll give you my opinion and
he shares it because he's learned to do
that you know and he'll just go yeah dan
i thought this and i thought that and
sometimes you'll bite back like you do
when you're a kid and then sometimes
you'll reflect on the next day going and
i'll see what you mean you know it was
always interesting to give you another
little life view when you're going for
the feedback thing you know the
academies imagine me walking in yeah i
must think i know yeah
that must have been such a weird moment
and then start telling you about
football and your own son and um really
yeah but you've had that you have to
swallow it do you like it there's no
following no just do it because i
believe in don't undermine the teacher
yeah that's what i mean you sit down
yeah yeah yeah that's old school i want
to be at the school in the morning of
the teacher that's not something no no
no no
no no no no no no no no no no absolutely i
know they're teachers for a reason
listen they learn yeah so i'll be saying
to the coach they spend it's their
feedback listen and learn so they were
cool i never i never ever got involved
with the coaches and went whoa hang on a
minute
this is not my page would that be
typical with your players do you think
that your players would generally do you
ever get pushed back from players are
you happy oh yeah no yeah yeah so it
depends on your character some
right so give you an example you're in a
group room feedback in my day was almost
cringe you know you'd be embarrassed you
don't do that anymore right the
languaging is important the tone that
you use i've got a negative tone in my
voice so i have to be really positive
because people just hear a negative i
learned that many years ago even though
i'm quite a positive i think i'm quite
positive guys
you're self-aware that you've got it
you've got to know that your tone my
tone is like oh and it's hard to find it
harsh you know what i mean yeah so
therefore you need more positives to
take away that so when you get feeding
back to people it's like what you
thought are you showing you know my dad
he'd show you something go what are you
doing that for and immediately on the
back foot so if you're the wrong
character you fight are we as if i said
what are your thoughts different words
right so your brain works didn't you go
oh yeah i was thinking that there you go
well i was thinking that i was thinking
that was saying oh okay fine well what
about if you thought that and you fought
that and you thought that then it just
changed that's specific to the player
though do you feel like some players you
some players you go mate what are you
playing at or another players know some
players can take the group environment
not many yeah not many want to be that
weird thing when you feel a bit
embarrassed or a bit on you is this new
therefore
no no no we've learned the players were
the same
he says the coaches are the managers of
learn the players
it's you as the coach and the manager
they've got to learn to diffuse you not
there yeah but the easiest thing in the
world is to go in and give them what it
is yeah you are doing that everyone can
do that but guess what you feel better
for about three minutes and then you go
in your office you go that ain't going
to work is it because now they feel
awful make them feel better not me my
job is to swallow the grenade like on
the cartoons you know yeah yeah jump on
it yeah and let them
breathe and learn
play things you know when there needs to
about what and
be the element of discipline i've read
about a fine will that you had in the uh
yeah that come from rugby um sports
scientist mark hower great guy great
operator with us at burnley um
yeah this idea of rugby to take away the
diffuse silly
like lack of professional things you
know
kit lying around kit on the train just
little things shoddy time time keeping
not the big stuff i mean no the big
stuff would come to me but little stuff
so we bought in a fine wheel and on the
fine wheel some would be money some
would be um payback of money and some
would be
things like um
you know
you pay you you get a fine one of them
would be spin again for someone's car to
be valid so you spin again whatever
number it comes out your number he knows
to pay for your car to be valid nice um
one that was a good one one went down um
they have to buy dinner for you either
you and a mate you and your partner
whichever wife whatever it may be family
of course someone tops it don't they so
someone hits the big one bottle of
shampoo and all that you know well you
know they're screwing because the bill's
giving it like 400 they're like i love
it
and then what happens is then the
receipts presented to that person that
personally
yeah no that's just an example um we had
to sit in a room there's a river by the
training ground we'd have to sit in the
river uh for a minute um
slap dance hilarious
well if you got a lap dance you'd have
to spin again so you're fine to get the
number of so when you do the lap dance
genius
genius cringe yeah exactly yeah hideous
the genius negotiable these happen if
you if you if you're well they're
negotiable until the point when you've
got to do it what you can do right the
whole group are sitting there going no
you got to do it wow
and it starts with a process no buying
so we go right lads it's an idea what
are your thoughts and at first you know
you get resistors and all that and then
once i get involved with it like buzzing
and somebody properly like dying you
know someone sing sing in front of the
creek you're surprised how you just see
a grey man crushed i was singing in
front of his mates by the way yes
crushed so and some of you find somebody
some of me 50 quid never never mad stuff
not like huge stuff
um
and some would be you you win two free
spins uh you spin for someone else to
spell it's incredible
yeah so you put some fun stuff in here
so you could actually win from it
um yeah and there was one that was
straight 350 and it used to come around
in the last because i don't want that
one well it'd be 350 for leaving a cup
on a table
oh yeah yeah no we were big on it yeah
yeah but used to be specifically
how are you in the canteen why can't you
just lift your plate right and put it on
a trolley come on
yeah you're a human right you can lift
to play imagine being at home your mum
she's going to kill me
so they're just simple life things these
are not they're not going to make you
win a game but they might just give you
a little bit more of a core to work from
you know you know what's mad certainly
you've got to think as well like
different people have been raised
different yeah you know what i mean so
this is like you're in my house you're
giving them an alliance of simplicity
this is not these are small things but i
mean so mathematically the big stuff you
know someone's an hour late training or
whatever that comes to me when they get
a proper fine or whatever it may be
worry about all the little stuff that
just keep it tight and show a bit
respect you know why kit man why throw
your kit all over the floor i'm sure you
can just leave it on your place you know
i mean just little things but it's
probably quite quite popular isn't it
these kind of things like they're good
for teams
i don't know they tell me some
environments just won't do that they
expect everything to literally be done
literally everything to be done so
managers are happy with that that's fine
i'm not here to judge we just created an
environment that we thought would suit
what we were trying to achieve that's
all we did and what did you do we just
played into it
because you've got another group right
some people see that right so we can
laugh about it and you'd buy into it
right that's just
lovely right but yeah yeah but that
doesn't mean everyone does this is it
they're like whoa
now what you think we're going to win
against mount city because i do a lap
dance on someone yeah trust me that i
ain't going to say that
dance i want to do it boy exactly so the
point is we're trying to build
connectivity by stripping back that so
when you're in front of your group you
can do anything right yeah and we're
together yeah singing in front look
after little small side of games we used
to have um get in the middle of the
group and we'd all clap you up to dance
yeah
yeah
crushed that'd be me yeah but but the
idea was if you strip off nobody if you
strip off their ego yeah and they
realize you'd laughing with them yeah
not against them but but getting some
people to buy into that is not easy
because they're like so resistant
they're like why you embarrass me well
we're not we're trying to take away the
immigration in front of our collective
group we're a hardcore group we can do
what we need to do in front of each
other make no mistake and not only did
everybody buy into it
yeah i mean we started early and once
you get the early adopters they spread
the word so players start signing
knowing that this is coming yeah yeah so
they almost got it all right yeah that's
the way it goes you've got man this is
building an environment it's not about
the wheel the wheel's not going to win
your game i'm well aware
is that creating the environment for the
team to operate freely together
absolutely to explain i remember when
the person who was on the fines the fine
man like if you've come in you you've
come in late and he's only he's seen you
maybe
don't say nothing no sir and obviously
it's his job to
say it to keep us disciplined and then
you'd be like oh you're so busy right no
pressure yeah yeah yeah man
so if no one comes up with a fight then
you spin the wheel and someone gets
fined oh just for just for the sake of
yeah right well because i know that
they're not they're doing that don't
don't say anything yeah and once they
once you unwrap it oh they're like well
he did that yeah yeah yeah
you get about 20 speeds start singing
and then the other thing the other thing
to give you a reference point of this so
we i've always heard me under we nicked
this idea out of rugby loads people
nicked it off us
and put it out there as well we we were
so we see interviews man's going yeah
yeah you've got this spin wheel and
they've all taken theirs
yeah i always
if i've knicked stuff
i'll hold my hands no no we got that
idea from them and we just made our own
yeah
our people have nicked our first photo i
finally taken it to other clubs and i
sold it in the press yeah we do this
admits that because some people was
again in especially in the content
creating industry like they steal your
ideas mind your sword i'm inspired by
that or whatever mind you
show me a good good manager i'll show
you a good thief yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's managers most managers and nick tom
all over me and i've nick loads i've
made them but it's boring
it's it's
like some of it is authentic to you of
course i've got a few sayings and things
i do of course but you do there are
other things you think i like that i
just and sometimes from weird and
wonderful things it doesn't have to be
from football for business from like i
said music and people i've met who's
this a bit of gold and you think what
that'll do imitation and flattery and
all that oh man some of the greatest
entertainers i won't name the name of
this one because he's cancelled but he
used to go into the streets
i don't think we need to know now
for another moment
he used to go into the streets of new
york or wherever it may be he'd watch
the street dancers
go back
add intermediate thing and then we'd
think he's created the greatest thing
since i spread but yeah a lot of them do
go on to the streets go and listen to
street performers and whatnot and you
get inspiration man from from going to
that level when you sign players would
you
bring into your decision-making process
their character like would you think are
you going to be up for the wheel of
fortune but you get that it's another
thing you know the media go they used to
say things like oh sean you know i could
just say um it seems like you're always
signing good characters nice guy who
doesn't want to sign good characters he
said show me a manager who doesn't want
to sign everyone wants to but would you
make it part of would you meet the
player and make it happen
at least you have to find out what you
can yeah you know it's not easy and the
reason why often we we didn't go into
the european market heavy was because
the board of directors made it clear to
me can we get good people can we survive
in the premier league can we then sell
them on yeah well so you need to know
more and more and more about them to try
and keep your mistakes minimal yes when
you start going to europe it's very
difficult to find out what the
background you've got to remember my
coaching staff had known i've known
players since i know their education
managers night because my background i
went into you know watford as a youth
coach and so i know education people so
you can check them out you i mean
properly check them out
so you're edging your bets that they're
probably going to still be that type of
person but then you've gone about good
characters and the one i always used
because it was quite heavily put about
was joey barton
never said to me you're saying joey you
know i saw a great coach and i said well
joey bart now he is a great character
but they don't know that they're going
to assume he wasn't yeah they assumed he
wasn't he was fantastic with us
fantastic with us on the picture and off
the paper you know i was mad i was
watching everton it might have been they
played it whenever i watched them
recently right and um i remember saying
to myself you know what
i think they're gonna do all right in
the sense of uh because they're
obviously in a good at the moment it's
early to doors but relegation battle but
it's not it's early doors right but i
remember saying to myself they've got
tarkovsky
uh dwight mcniel and they've come from a
sean dash team so they're definitely
first things first gonna be putting
putting it in which is gonna think so
yeah but you never mind so yeah yeah
sean press conferences
it seems to me watching you in press
conferences that you enjoyed them you
like to have a bit of fun in there is
that true
well it grows you know you do that many
that at first you you you're doing all
the right messages saying all the right
things and you get a bit longer in the
tooth and longer in your career and you
think hang on i mean everyone's saying
the right things are all saying you know
i mean the latest thing you know another
thing that we laugh at in the game is
you know people come out with
terminologies now so it's like you know
you sound pseudo intellect by coming out
with certain football technologies and
we just laugh you know he's got but but
but
seriously
you have to a little bit because if not
you sound like a dull art you know so
sort of the press love that stuff so you
have to do a little bit enough i will
say to young managers and say look put
enough out there like oh yeah he's got
something to say
but not so much where they're going
another one's you know recreating
football football we've got 140 years
but everyone is making out they're
redesigning it you know what i mean um
so yeah without my version of the press
over a number of years i just tried to
be me just trying to have a bit fun i
like a bit of fun i like about dry humor
i don't think there's anything wrong you
know that scary word that you're not
allowed using or banter wrong with
throwing that around and having a bit of
rapport you know with reporters so i
just always thought well
be yourself be authentic and if the time
comes when i can break a moment just by
having a bit of fun why not but i wasn't
so refreshing
you know people sort of think
it's like that comedian thing when they
go go make us laugh you know as if you
know you're going to men they're looking
at you what do you mean
it's just a natural moment that's my
point it's just naturally like today
we're just naturally chatting and you
just something will flick in your brain
and you just go oh yeah you can dive on
that so can i before we get into our
scene there's a few like real fun things
about one thing i did want to ask you
about and that was
the uh correlation between the internet
social media and footballers form
like i want to talk about that man yeah
no it's tough i mean you know another
popular myth misconception whichever you
put it sean nice and like the social
media absolute nonsense um got nothing
against it i've just never seen its
place with players because i think it
brings undue pressure yeah
i get it from a brandon i get that some
of these players are huge you know i get
the brand inside of it but i don't know
about talking about the game and talking
about your performances and i just think
why
would you get something to explain
how do you uh
how do you govern this right so just
think of this logically just bear with
me
someone on a on a on an app or whatever
they call it instagram right it's
feeding back to you knows nothing about
you nothing about the game possibly
nothing about what you've gone through
nothing about what you've done to get to
where you've got to and what you do
but they're powerful enough to affect
you as a human
and yet the coach who's seen you
develops knows everything about you
somehow doesn't
that is a weird thing about psychology
about modern life psychology more likes
and all that means more than the people
who actually know in the room
professional people who can feedback
your help your support you guide you
sort of means more for people who don't
know anything about you
to to give you a like than it does the
people in the room i've always i'm still
flummoxed by that just on a logical
would you try and counsel your players
to not be on no i just offer them the
the reasons right so we had a rule that
no football talk
um
but i but i shared with them why i said
because it's just going to bring you
know people talk about referees it's
just gonna be in trouble why you know
what i mean so i just go that's the
reason why that's just that and we'd
have a bit of fun with it there were
certain lines we put it to the group for
the spin wheel we've got oh what about
this and we put something up there put
on social media
and then let's go and then we put it to
a vote
is that you know some of the borderline
mentioning about football so but it was
actually a safe garden it was to say
lads just take that away because guess
what it's another less thing to worry
about when your football are now
football they're traveling to a game
right this is my way of thinking cause
i'm like this people who know me for a
long time i am like this
strip it back get focused so why add to
it i'm on the way to a game right why do
i need to be on the phone answering i
don't know whatever it is why are there
tickets and did it i'm like just
stripping that back so that when i sit
there in my place i'm ready i'm zoned in
i'm ready
now that might be old fashioned but that
just seems to me like logic if i'm a
performer of any kind be ready yeah it's
pretty click all the boxes
make sure i've rested well make sure i'm
hydrated make sure them things not worry
about whether someone on social media
said that i'm going to play well or not
today you know whatever
i'm being flippant but you know what
yeah okay but it's like
it works both ways when you're
performing well
and then you're reading all of the
comments yeah superpower yeah yeah but
then it's like well you know what's
going to happen because it's life you're
going to have a bit of bad form
and that's what it's going to be a
madness for you you've got to find a
reality liner yeah man and when you find
your own reality line you could probably
deal with all that stuff yeah yeah
because some are amazing they deal with
all kinds of noise but they they've just
got a skill in there but in their mind
that they can deal with that they're not
managing
disconnect you see the way that you see
that you see the way that you would
handle the press when you would do that
and the way that you would manage the
media and have a bit of fun with them
were you doing that because you found it
fun and were you doing that to protect
the players in the way that we're
supposed to take the players just maybe
i just thought you know
the only things i wouldn't go into and
this is more of respect than i didn't
talk about other people's players i
didn't talk about women signing players
or not signing players didn't talk about
other managers very rarely do i question
other managers yeah even when they've
come for me loads come for me and i'll
just leave it because i don't know i've
got enough respect from my old school
beliefs of being brought up by my mum
and dad mm-hmm
so therefore that's why i do it got that
inner voice in me under my mum going
well
there's a little uh rule i live by i
call it the uh seven p's
is
you need to try that tonight
on a totally different subject sean
you've been to the grand canyon you
weren't particularly impressed
well
there's the story goes from uh my mate
ian and my assistant manager um he got
interviewed about our life and all that
he told this story about the grand
canyon to give you a quick version of it
um he where the end product he made out
that i wasn't impressed by it and all
that but he said it tongue-in-cheek they
rub it and then it all gets thrown back
at me the truth is we were naive we were
traveling around america we stand in
vegas we had a car we decided to go to
the grand canyon thinking it's
you know we do it in a couple of hours
um jump in the car we're cracking on at
90 85 90 you know an hour miles an hour
whatever it was
so we were on this massively long
straight road dual carriageway going
into the desert must have been i think
we took a photo of it i think we clocked
it at 18 miles just a straight road so
this cop car goes the other way does
like in like in dukes of azeroth in my
day spins down spins down the bit in
between dust everywhere it comes flying
up behind me wonder where he's going
pulls us over does us for speeding now
we've got to get to the grand canyon at
55 kilometers an hour 665 in certain
bits 55 daylight and we were like oh
and then you see a sign i remember
seeing it it was like
263 kilometers
well i just said
so we cracked on so we get there
and we have literally about an hour or
so to look through the grand canyon so
we're just like looking through it and i
was amazed i loved it you know he knows
i loved it really but he sold the story
that i did and all that and so he made a
story but that's the truth we got back
in the car and now we have to go back at
50 and 65 k's an hour because if we get
done again he gets put inside because he
could drive i couldn't drive i wasn't
old enough you know
no for the insurance
he was 24 24 whatever it was
so he would have got done and put inside
for the night so now we have to go back
dead on the speed limit it chocolates
ages it's got taken us five and a half
six hours we get back there at midnight
now we left first thing midnight have a
fat burger
john kel in bed like absolutely meant to
go for a night out with her
the
certainly about 11 yeah 10 and a half
11. now it's like the average speed
limit when you get on an average speed
limit you're like mate that's already
done another quick one we were on a tour
in a car went around for sort of four or
five weeks and we went through yosemite
park right brilliant so not naive again
for one why won't he yeah i'll do him
back here for one won't he buy she said
um where you guys off to and he went oh
uh the yosemites and she went man i
haven't heard of that maybe yosemite
crying with laughter crying
so anyway so he's a bright lad to be
fair to him so i mustn't do him down too
much so we go off setting off through
the desert blah blah blah blah come to
yosemite park i swear to you we've gone
off like this right shorts t-shirt
flip-flops we don't realize it was shirt
the night four because of snow oh wow
and this is like in june i swear so we
get up there we've got we've got
pictures from back in the early
old-fashioned camera not like a iphone
of like six foot snow drifts and we're
in sleep yeah
it's bizarre it's the most bizarre thing
it's only for a stretch as you go higher
there's another um little quick story a
myth that you might want to
bust but
danny dyer he he he
broke one of your team talks up like he
interacted when your team talks no so uh
who's become a friend serge um sergey
perzono's with kasabian yes so i became
a friend and and or i became a friend of
his by the way not
and he invited me to the evening during
his wedding so danny dyer was there and
he had a couple of chandeliers i think
possibly um as i die and uh they had
like a you know them it's like a taxi
with a camera in the back yeah
so yeah so uh the camera's on yeah so he
was going to die she died she gives a
team talk tiffany's with sir josh he
gets a team talking like so i did i got
my team taught properly down the bottom
of the camera that's amazing okay is
that about it it's not a real team
tournament
no serger's got it isn't it it's not
like
this is his wedding
it was a proper proper reading
that'd be really funny now because
that's going to feel like we're in the
moment there we go yeah that could be
something on the wheel yeah yeah you
ever lose it
sean i think that's that's done i must
say thank you so much for coming on this
is our debut as well um and you know
you've enjoyed it in our first ever
sport bible stories well i hope it
builds from here and we're on a start
point or i'm on your start point thank
you so much if you had to go to the
grand canyon again and one of us had to
be your wingman which one would you take
neither you have to you have to pick one
of us this is huge for us
well you'd rather not go so you could go
to the ground
i'd have more banner
i love it it's all about you
gave me the eyes to suggest it was made
estate yeah yeah exactly
[Music]
that's what i was defining against
barcelona and wembley
i should have changed at halftime and
poop cheese and park and messi
that was a mistake
if i had played jason park against messi
i think would have beat him
i really do